foreign
[Music]
don't worry you boys got this
hey hey
over here kitty kitty
and down
I
I'm past a second time
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again
prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
foreign
I'm nobody I ain't even seen nothing I'm
not even seeing anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all shed
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
foreign
[Music]
all right